Bob Costas the Hall of Fame broadcaster
joining us on the program good morning
Bob how are you I'm okay Dan how are you
I'm doing okay trying to figure out how
we get baseball back like now I'm
hearing maybe there's a World Cup type
scenario if if we get something up later
in the summer what are you hearing as
what would actually be a distinct
possibility well they have to get in
some regular-season games to make it
representative even if they go to a
tournament type thing for the postseason
and I think that baseball fans would
accept anything I've said this before
anything short of running the bases
clockwise they'd accept because of the
unique circumstances they'd accept a
world series in a dome or a warm weather
neutral site they'd accept all the
experimentation now is the time
electronic plate umpire pitch clock with
nobody on base everything fiddle with
different postseason concepts but you
got to play at least a representative
number of regular-season games before
you concede even an expanded playoff
field the latest thing which you were
just detailing is not something that
they would go to on a permanent basis
but it might be underlined might there's
lots of proposals out there but it might
be the best solution because players do
not want to be quarantined for several
months these are young people with young
families in many cases that's not going
to work even if the stands are empty
which is certainly going to be the case
at the outset if not throughout in 2020
if they're able to play at all even with
no fans in the stands playing in your
home ballpark is going to be so much
easier you've got all the facilities and
everything else in place and then
players would be able to go home and on
the road you quarantine them in a single
hotel that seems that seems doable but
as you look at it from a medical
standpoint we're not experts but we can
see that there are a lot of hurdles to
clear before they can say with some sort
of assurance they can responsibly say
yes this is safe to do not just
practical to do but safe to do do you
work backwards if you're baseball I know
that Scott Boras said hey we could have
baseball right after
and you could have a World Series dinner
I don't know if you say this is the last
date that we would have baseball now we
work back and say can we get in 100
games or whatever is going to be
constitutes a fair and representative of
a season I think 80 is okay remember
1981 they played a split season because
of a strike so you had separate Division
champions from the first half in the
second half the Dodgers wound up winning
the World Series and nobody considers
that illegitimate but your point is
well-taken
you got to work backwards because
assuming if you're able to play in some
way at all in 2020 you're then assuming
there's going to be a full season in
2021
fingers crossed if that's the case you
can't play into January and then turn
around and have spring training yeah
it's just you you hear all these
scenarios and I applaud these leagues
for thinking out of the box I just get
nervous when I hear these arbitrary
dates where you know we're gonna start
now we're gonna we plan on playing this
many games we we don't know this changes
every day it changes it feels like a
couple times a day
I just don't know and Dave Roberts to
the Dodgers manager and said hey whoever
wins this year there's no asterisk
attached to this I don't want to worry
about it an asterisk I want to worry
about him can we actually play then we
can worry about the damn asterisk after
this when do you think there's a start
date that you would say that that to me
sounds plausible
I wouldn't even venture a guess
everything keeps changing even with the
experts from a medical standpoint it's
just an educated guess so the leagues
all of them not just baseball they're
all right to have various contingency
plans best-case scenarios worst-case
scenarios everything in between and I
think this is a good opportunity for
baseball to send up all the trial
balloons you know I heard one that's
floating around I wish I had thought of
it myself and this would be for when
they're able to play a full season and
things have returned to normal we talked
about this before Dan baseball has an
interest in creating more postseason
revenue
and more inventory and therefore revenue
and one suggestion we talked about a
couple of months ago was only the one
division winner the number one gets a
pie and the other two division winners
had to be thrown in with the wildcards
and I didn't like that because it
minimizes the importance of the regular
season and puts those division winners
in a crapshoot here's a new idea I wish
I could claim it but I've heard it three
division winners as ever for wildcards
so you've expanded the postseason by
four teams two additional teams in each
league but here's the way it goes all
three division winners get a buy which
they've earned now you've got a knockout
series where the one wild card that will
emerge into the division series has to
win two games one plays for one game on
the home field of the number one wild
card two plays three on the home field
is number two the two survivors meet on
the home field of the highest remaining
seed and the winner moves into the
division series now
you've expanded the playoffs yes you
provided television with additional
single elimination games which they love
but you've actually put more emphasis on
the long regular season because the
division winners stand completely apart
from the wild-card round and now the
wild-card survivor has to win two games
instead of one use pitchers they're at a
disadvantage going into the postseason
you've accomplished two things you've
modernized by expanding the playoffs but
you've also put additional emphasis
old-school-style
on the regular season I wish I thought
of it myself is this a one-off or do you
would you like this proposed as baseball
move forward when we actually have a
regular you know 162 game schedule
I think this makes sense going forward
with a full season under normal
circumstances what they do this year I'd
be open to anything this year because
the circumstances are so different this
time around I think baseball fans would
accept any have you called a game with
no fans na o with no fans with no fans
um well you know I was the voice of the
spirits of st. Louis in the mid 70s and
James you know there were some games
then and you're a basketball guy I swear
the the spirits against the San Antonio
Spurs and here's Marvin Barnes right in
front of me as I'm sitting courtside
about the inbound guarded by George
Gervin and there's a crowd of 812 in a
nineteen thousand seat arena you got
time for a story yes okay Rudy Marx key
who we all know as the first and
long-running sports TV critic for the
USA Today now happily retired in Florida
Rudy was the director of operations for
the spirits of st. Louis and now there's
a timeout and they've announced the
crowd as something like 3000 or
something and I look around and this
clusters of fans and it doesn't add up
so I go to Rudy and I say Rudy it's bad
enough that we have this tiny crowd but
now we're going to lie about it like
three or four times over and this is
what he says did it ever occur to you
you little wiseass that maybe maybe
there are some people that the
concession stands or at the restrooms
and I say Rudy let's test your premise
let's suppose there was a sellout let's
suppose there were nineteen thousand
fans here what's the chance that at any
given time other than halftime ninety
five hundred of them are buying a hotdog
or relieving themselves Thank You Saul
paucity goes I used to go we're talking
to Bob Costas I used to go to the
Cincinnati Royals games and we would
sneak in and I could eventually end up
in the front row I've sat in the front
row when the Bulls came to town with
Howard Porter
they had Jerry so I actually saw Jerry
Sloan play in person
Bob wise like all of these you know
these you know it was the Royals against
the Bulls and nobody cared and they
would announce the crowd at like 2000
and and we actually counted one night
and it was 519 because the game wasn't
interesting but you know they behold
we're gonna lie about the size of a
crowd I witness
at first hand you know with this
Cincinnati since the Narrows but I don't
know how that would affect you if you
call the game and there's no crowd there
how much do you play off of that crowd
when you're calling a game oh you have
to not just when the crowd surges on a
big play you'd be missing that
excitement but let's say it's just
baseball there's a murmur of the crowd
at all times I heard Joe Buck the other
night on real sports on HBO with Bryant
Gumbel Joe thought there was some merit
to the idea of pumping in crowd sound
yeah I'm okay now I don't know I'm
trying that yeah everything you can try
every out of the box fair under these
circumstances I'm fine with that
the Bulls documentary you want you oh
yeah
haven't missed a second of it I think
it's great what are you because you're
involved in this because NBC carried the
NBA for such a long period of time you
were there from Michael's final game
with the Bulls did you know at the time
that was going to be his final game of
the Bulls I think we all strongly
suspected it and that's why even as
exciting and significant as that game
was simply as an NBA Finals series it
was one of the best but my comments at
the end I tried to frame it I didn't
know for sure that it was the end but I
assumed it was a very strong possibility
so in addition to just calling what was
a very exciting game I tried to frame it
in in that context but this was the end
of one of the most memorable runs by a
team in American sports history and
certainly one of the most transcendent
players in any sport I don't know if
Babe Ruth was his beloved when he played
when he went around these other parks
because Michael is Bill was beloved you
know fans couldn't wait to see him
even if he was gonna get 40 on their
team I don't know do you recall if Babe
Ruth was I know he was a phenomenon but
was he beloved the way Michael was
beloved each town do I recall it
firsthand
and a mystery card on a ball game and
and took my date on ladies days right
Walter Johnson and the senator is smart
has to sit down now do you think that
babe was was admired that way of
anything you've ever heard her read yeah
he was a gigantic force and even though
it seems like well it doesn't seem like
it is a hundred years ago in the
nineteen twenties baseball on the
country are moving into a different area
at the beginning of some kind of mass
communication you got radio and and
whatnot but still there's enough
distance so that everything that someone
like Ruth did for that matter a Jesse
Owens or a Red Grange or a Jack Dempsey
any of the big heroes of that era Joe
Lewis a little bit later there's an
element of myth and legend surrounding
it and maybe some of the stories are
apocryphal you don't have that now we
get to see everything and then we get to
replay it and dissect it and analyze it
what would Babe Ruth's called shot be a
controversy at all or something that
well I saw it this way you saw it that
way today yeah in ten seconds we'd know
whether he did it or not
I wonder how the Bulls would do now we
get really grew tired of Golden State
Warriors it felt like people grew tired
of the Patriots people grew tired of the
San Antonio Spurs if the Bulls were
playing now and had this dynasty would
we treat them the same way would they be
as beloved because we tend to chop up
everything nowadays and everything is
available there they wear out their
welcome well Michael Jordan was a
singular figure taking nothing away from
other great players including the great
players Steph Curry on or on on the
Golden State Warriors there was
something about Jordan if if you
imagined from central casting a leading
man for that whole decade or more
that person is Michael Jordan so I think
he would still be just as compelling but
your larger point is true then nothing
is fully appreciated anymore nothing is
in our business and you'll understand
the context in which I say this has
there ever been someone better at what
he did an hour
business than Vin Scully or Jim McKay
hosting the Olympics I guarantee you if
they were each 40 years old and plying
their trade on national television today
there'd be all kinds of social media
site being asked them you know
and people calling them an idiot while
misspelling idiot in they're moronic
hosts not nothing nothing nothing even
the best gets full appreciation anymore
so you know what would it be different
sure it would it's only a little more
than twenty years ago but it seems like
eons ago you're right I wonder how they
would critique Vin Scully style now oh
you think you're so good you don't have
to have an analyst they're like right
yourself hey Paula tree Robert Frost and
and give me the balls and just right oh
you're right thanks for making me laugh
hey great to talk to you hope
everything's well and we appreciate your
time as always bob thanks bob costas all
the Famer MLB Network host